we've talked about whether Donald Trump
is a full-blown authoritarian he's not
really a conservative on any issues but
he's also not a liberal it's sort of
hard to pin down what Trump's beliefs
are in some broader sense I want to
present to you a term that explains and
describes the politics of Trump this is
really an important segment okay
regressive populism now hold on a second
I'm not saying regressive as an ad
hominem this has nothing to do with
regressive in the sense that it's
sometimes used as an ad hominem in terms
of regressive left regressive popular
populism is a very specific term and
I've been reading a lot of sort of
academic nonfiction related to politics
and media for a new project I have which
I'll announce at some point soon and I
was reading a book called waves of
rancor by Hilliard and Keith and I came
across a paragraph that described
regressive populism this book is nearly
twenty years old
it describes Donald Trump this paragraph
was distinguishing a different sort of
right-wing movement from the theocratic
right sometimes known as the religious
right there's an alternative called
regressive populism let's take a look at
it because it really explains what Trump
is quote Berlet and Quigley add to this
theocratic right movement others as
advocates of regressive progressive
populism PATRIOT armed militia and white
supremacy groups the overtly racist
far-right organizations such as the Ku
Klux Klan Christian Patriots racist
skinheads neo-nazis and right-wing
revolutionaries promoting in various
combinations and to varying degrees
authoritarianism is in a phobia
conspiracy theories nativism racism
sexism homophobia anti-semitism
demagoguery and scapegoating we've
talked about left-wing vs. right-wing
populism this is much more nuanced and
it's a very relevant perspective and it
really explains what's going on right
now and how it relates to the religious
right which this isn't Trump is not the
religious right Trump talks about God to
pander and he did that in his address to
that joint session of Congress you
today but it's overall a different type
of appeal that Trump is making and it's
sometimes called just populist but most
reasonable people people realize that
it's not the same populism as in the
message of Bernie Sanders was populism
it is regressive populism it's populism
based on conservatism or conserving and
sometimes it's more about not just
conserving but regressing to the past
and that's the opposite of progress all
populism will usually acknowledge
economic and security Bernie did that
Trump did that but regressive populism
proposes as solutions to that inequality
varying degrees of regression this might
be finding scapegoats to blame for
grievances whether it's undocumented
immigrants welfare programs dangerous
Muslims whatever and the solutions
proposed by regressive populism will
further prop up the elites and grow the
kleptocracy or oligarchy progressive
populism the populism of bernie is
actually looking to hold elites in the
wealthy accountable for their role in
creating the problem and make them
responsible for solutions regressive
populism that of Trump actually wants to
deflect attention away from the elites
and the wealthy and big corporations and
scapegoat others usually to benefit the
rich and there's a really big overlap
between the regressive populism of Trump
and the calling cards of the radical
right this includes the neo-nazis the
white supremacists the black separatists
like the Nation of Islam most of those
groups scapegoat a tyrannical government
Jews and minorities very very often
Trump is doing that to varying degrees
and with more subtlety note that none of
this requires Trump or anyone to be
personally racist or anti-semitic if he
has racist or anti-semitic people
involved fine
but I want to be super clear about that
this is an appeal to those ideas and I
think it explains so clearly what we're
seeing right now so I think populism in
a more general sense can often be a good
thing because it means that you're
you're listening to the will of the
constituents and but it has to be kind
of matched with this this sort
of consistency so if you look at Bernie
Sanders he's been the same guy for 30
years in Congress he doesn't really
change based on the political winds he
doesn't change based on political
expediency but Donald Trump I mean he's
he's changed so much in the past ten
years especially and I mean if you look
at this guy he's he's kind of appealed
to the worst in people and that's how he
goes about doing his populism
and I don't think that's the right way
to go you're bringing up something
interesting which is a populist appeal
does not necessarily mean that it is one
that will be good for the majority of
people populism can be appealing to the
masses with particular messages
inclinations or or biases and populism
in and of itself I think is
misunderstood in that it's objectively
progressive and here we are seeing very
specifically regressive populism really
really interesting I recommend the book
waves of rancor from I believe it's from
1999 Hilliard and Keith it really will
break down the different right-wing
movements that exist their use of media
and messaging and I just randomly came
across this paragraph I put it out on my
Instagram page David Pakman and the more
I thought about it the more it clearly
applies to what we're seeing under the
trump administration make sure that you
join us on reddit where you can discuss
this and any other stories that you're
interested in david pakman.com slash
read it that's our e d di t today's show
is brought to you by go daddy where you
can buy your own domain name build a
website or use any of Go Daddy's
business tools you can save 30 percent
at Tri godaddy.com slash David GoDaddy
has actually been the official host of
the David Pakman show web site for many
many many years the 24/7 customer
support has been a very good thing for
us I've called them at really odd times
when we've had website issues and they
are always available they are the
largest domain registrar and whether you
have a new idea you're an established
business you're creating a personal
website or moving your large enterprise
/ - GoDaddy they can do it all 13
million customers try it and get 30% off
at try godaddy.com / David